[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we're going to be discussing
a Lord Voldemort and all of his
Horcruxes as a known proponent of dark
magic Tom Riddle began experimenting
with the dark arts at a very young age
in the film adaptation of the half-blood
Prince the pensive reveals one of
Dumbledore's most important memories
which takes us all the way back to the
year 1938 Dumbledore is shown visiting a
very troubled looking boy sitting alone
in the room of an orphanage
during Dumbledore's visit to the
orphanage he reveals to the boy that he
is a wizard and subsequently shows him
an impressive display a magical ability
riddle is in all and shortly after this
moment Dumbledore invites him to
Hogwarts Tom Riddle was of course a
terrifying hostile child who tormented
the other orphans but this was not
something that Dumbledore knew about
until later on after riddle began
attending the school
Dumbledore researched riddle and became
more familiar with his existence however
he was still mostly unaware of the true
potential of his dark nature after Harry
is finished with the pensive he has the
following exchange with Dumbledore did
you know sir then did I know that I had
just met the most dangerous Dark Wizard
of all time No
after spending some time at Hogwarts a
young Tom Riddle would eventually come
to befriend professor Horace Slughorn
his then potions Professor Slughorn had
a tendency to choose favorites from his
classes and he had a keen eye for
identifying if someone would go on to
achieve greatness in some capacity and
would always take great pride in their
accomplishments Tom Riddle like Harry
Potter would go on to become one of
Slughorn's absolute favorites while a
student at Hogwarts riddle was a very
impressive student who expressed an
unparalleled ability to learn there is
one particular branch of magic however
that riddle may have learned a little
bit too much about it has been expressed
that Slughorn was responsible for
providing riddle with information on
Horcruxes the same form of dark magic
that was instrumental in Voldemort rise
to power
Slughorn served head of Slytherin house
during his time at the school but
retired in the year 1981 at a fear Albus
Dumbledore does
that he had told Tom Riddle about these
Horcruxes a rather taboo subject that
should have never been discussed at all
Slughorn claimed ignorance for years
expressing that he had never told riddle
anything of the sort
even going as far as to tamper with his
own memories so the truth would never be
revealed however his truth did
eventually come out and it was shown
that Slughorn had given riddle perhaps a
little bit too much information on this
extremely sinister form of dark magic if
you don't know what a Horcrux is already
well you should but for the sake of the
video will briefly introduce the subject
anyway a Horcrux is an object in which a
dark witch or wizard has imbued part of
their soul the ultimate purpose of
creating a Horcrux is to achieve
immortality
however the truly sinister component of
creating a Horcrux is that in order to
produce one you must murder someone
there are only two known wizards who
have created the Horcrux
the first being Hereford the foul and
the second being Voldemort who produced
many Voldemort's first Horcrux is the
diary of Tom Riddle this was of course
created after Voldemort murdered Moaning
Myrtle in 1943 the second Horcrux is
helga hufflepuff's cup which was created
after the death of hep-c / Smith
sometime after 1946 Hepzibah was
mercilessly killed by Voldemort when he
spiked her cocoa with poison the third
Horcrux is Salazar Slytherin's locket
which was created after Voldemort
murdered a muggle
the fourth Horcrux is Nagini who became
a Horcrux after the death of Bertha
Jorkins the fifth Horcrux is Marvolo
Grant's ring which was produced after
Voldemort murdered his own father Tom
Riddle senior in 1943 the sixth Horcrux
is Rowena Ravenclaw's diadem which was
produced after Voldemort killed Anna Mae
Mian peasant sometime after 1946 and
Voldemort seventh Horcrux was of course
Harry Potter who became a Horcrux after
Voldemort's failed murder attempt while
the creation of Horcruxes is commonly
associated with immortality technically
aren't completely immortal because a
Horcrux can be destroyed so long as the
Horcruxes remain your safe but in the
case of Voldemort his Horcrux is dropped
off like flies after
Potter and gang discovered what they
need to do in order to destroy him
commonly Horcruxes are protected with
counter charms and jinxes this can make
it difficult to even approach them but
if you are fortunate enough to
circumvent these jinxes and counter
charms you can actually destroy them
here are some of the confirmed methods
basilisk fangs in the books and films
the fabled basilisk Fang is used to
destroy a couple of Voldemort's
Horcruxes including hufflepuff's cup and
Tom Riddle's diary this is because the
basilisks Fang contains basilisk venom
the true destructive agent that is
capable of taking down or Horcrux at one
point Harry uses Godric Gryffindor sword
to cut the roof of the basilisk mouth in
viewing the sword with basilisks venom
it was for this reason that the same
sword was able to destroy Marvolo
Gaunt's ring and Salazar Slytherin's
locket a fiend fire fiend fire is a form
of advanced dark magic a curse that
produces enchanted flames of immense
size and heat fiend fire destroys anyone
and anything in its path and it's
assumes the form of gigantic fiery
beasts like serpents chimeras and
Dragons fiend fire can destroy anything
and is responsible for destroying Rowena
Ravenclaw's diadem in the Room of
Requirement inside of Hogwarts the
diadem was kicked into fencing crabs are
an intentional fiend fire and we also
have the killing curse Avada Kedavra
it's one of the unforgivable curses and
misused by Voldemort to destroy the
Horcrux inside of Harry
however the destruction of the Horcrux
is achieved one thing is massively
important and that is the Horcrux is
beyond magical reconstitution it isn't
possible to magically fix certain types
of damage and it just so happens the
damage from basilisk venom fiend fire
and Avada Kedavra fit this criteria we
must remember that it is the container
that needs to be destroyed beyond
magical repair I've always wondered as
Voldemort was aware that his Horcrux was
being destroyed why didn't he go to any
effort to create more surely if he was
successful in creating seven of them
previously and was fully aware of the
process he could just create more as
they were destroyed
I knew the locations of the Horcruxes
because Dumbledore had figured them out
but since Dumbledore was now dead
wouldn't it have been easy for Voldemort
to create another that Harry didn't know
the location of this brings us to
Voldemort's obsession with the number 7
and his belief that the number 7 was of
particular importance in achieving
immortality in its strongest form when
Voldemort spoke with Sauron one of the
goals of the conversation was to confirm
seven pieces of soul but make the
concept of immortality through Horcruxes
even more powerful
Voldemort felt that splitting his soul
into more than seven pieces would
somehow lessen the strength of the power
a conversation between Harry and
Dumbledore supports this wouldn't it be
better make you stronger to have your
soul in more pieces I mean for instance
isn't seven the most powerfully magical
number wouldn't seven yes I think the
idea of a seven part soul would greatly
appeal to Lord Voldemort because of this
Harry is under the impression that
Voldemort would need to create seven
Horcruxes a statement which Dumbledore
corrects no Harry not seven Horcruxes
six the seventh part of his soul however
maimed resides inside his regenerated
body because Voldemort was so fixated on
the number seven and at being the most
magical number he felt that splitting
his soul into seven pieces and only
seven would provide him the highest
level of protection he avoided creating
additional Horcruxes because he felt
that it would contradict this sacred
number not only that but we are just
missing so much important information
about the creation of Horcruxes we don't
know how long it takes or how long it
would take to physically recover from
creating one perhaps given his current
position creating an additional Horcrux
would have rendered him vulnerable for
too long when Voldemort Horcruxes were
being destroyed he recognized that he
was in danger and probably felt the
rendering himself in a more vulnerable
state was not a good decision to make at
that time
it could have been time-sensitive by the
time Voldemort realized he was truly in
danger and needed further protection no
wizard before Voldemort was successful
in creating as many Horcruxes as he did
in fact only one other wizard ever was
successful in creating a Horcrux and
that was her / - foul who I mentioned
earlier to split your soul into seven
pieces seems as though it would take a
significant toll on your very existence
with each split taking more out of you
than the last the book mentions at one
point that Voldemort soul had already
been torn to the limit with his physical
appearance being a representation of
that so it makes sense that he would be
unable to create oh I think that seven
is just the maximum number of Horcruxes
that you can create period and this
would definitely explain valmores
obsession with that number it would also
explain why Voldemort seventh
inadvertent Horcrux destroyed him
because a creation of a seventh Horcrux
meant that his soul was now split into
eight conflicting with magic number
seven barring all of the above in mind
we also have to remember that Voldemort
was extremely arrogant he perhaps over
confidently believed that no one would
ever find all of his Horcruxes
particularly the diadem the book is
Odell Oh magic must even which can be
found it in the Hogwarts library was one
of the only books on the dark arts that
mentioned Horcruxes
however the Horcrux is proved to be such
a vile form of dark magic that even a
book on dark magic didn't discuss them
in much detail an excerpt from the book
reads as follows of the Horcrux
wickedest of magical inventions we shall
not speak nor give direction perhaps
Voldemort knowing that there was very
little available information on
Horcruxes believed that no one would
ever catch on or figure out how to
properly destroy them
perhaps his arrogance and his false
sense of security were what led to his
downfall and that's it for this video if
you enjoyed the content be sure to LIKE
the video and subscribe to the channel
until next time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]
you